it's evening class at the Bianchi Kadam
school one of the nearly 130 religious
schools and institutions in Kyrgyzstan
some of the students like cannot come
from remote areas he joined the school
six years ago I finished my normal
school and I have a certificate that I
finished the school and now I study in
University and here together we hear
sweeping we hear you think we here have
a good lessons and we hear live and it's
our second or second house students have
to be at least 16 years old before they
can apply to come here
the Constitution guarantees freedom of
Education and religion under the system
whoever wants to learn about religion
has the right after finishing secondary
school hub religious education is
supervised by institutions that are
mostly funded by charities both local
and international Kyrgyzstan being a
secular state educational system doesn't
include any religious studies whatsoever
for that the student must go to the
privately run religious schools but now
the government says it will introduce
reform to bring them more in line with
the national education system religious
education was banned during the Soviet
rule the government says it recognizes
that interest in religion has increased
since the fall of the Soviet Union but
after a few hundred Kyrgyz citizens
joined the ranks of ISIL in Iraq and
Syria the government has national
security concerns suddenly because you
don't know where this charity or this
foundation come from and what the main
ideas of this financial support of
religious education should be this
teaching program there should be the
teaching plan what kind of subjects will
be in the educational problem who is the
teachers does do they have the
sufficient indication in religious fear
critics
say students who only go to religious
schools are ill prepared to enter the
workforce but Abdallah says is what he
learns in the religious school combined
with his general studies and financial
accounting that will make him successful
in life the government is promising
students like him that the new bill will
merely provide a framework for religious
education one that will be in tune with
the secular identity of the country but
Abdel Hamid al-jazeera Bishkek in
Kyrgyzstan